you pacifically told me not to
double-dip but the power hoon italic
compelled me I've never had Nutella
before really excited about this I don't
know how I made it this long in my life
without it I don't even know what it is
I don't even know if it's like made out
of nuts and people have said this is
like God's gift to man and women I'm
excited to to see what the hype is about
do people just do this like people just
be like I had a bad day I'm just gonna
even tell him 100 calories per
tablespoon
that's insane all right I like this
consistency goo oh yeah I like this
little go I don't like the consistency
it's really thick this is so good oh
there's like a lot of chocolate at lunch
wow this is great
I don't like peanut butter but like this
is like peanut butters hot sister I want
a date I don't know it's not horrible
only it's the best thing ever though I
like it a lot I'm scared of that now
definitely have this like when a lady
comes over like hey I got some Nutella I
don't even know what is it's magic and
it's good for you too right no okay it's
not good trick I see what the hype is
about
this is Nutella banana mix kind of
grossed out by this I'm not gonna lie
low drop test oh there we go
mmm all right you got me
you know I don't like that it's
delicious
this is pretty much like Nutella banana
shake the consistency of this is like a
giant booger
I might even lick the bowl too just
because I feel like you couldn't serve
this to somebody I feel like you can say
hey come over here's like a bowl that I
put together for you but that's fine
because then you can just make more for
yourself and eat it in secrecy
this is like I just can't right now kind
of sandwich you've thrown your waistline
to the wind awful love I was really
hoping if I hated this one I can't talk
right now I just got to eat I wish you
could like feel this it's so crispy yeah
I know that's disgusting
she's good like lunch lunch room
collateral you can like make your way to
the top this tastes like if you took
this more to like a really creative like
chef and who's England than that I fix
it for you never meet girls you heart
would get make happy with this you can
have a party and they make a bunch of
the all women there they'll love it
everyone that actually beat my
expectations which we're already really
high I get why people are like super
excited about it I'm glad I lost my
virginity today yeah this sucks
I gotta go out and buy like that's of it
probably not I am definitely converted
I'm a newt Alito like I'm in love I
don't know if I'm a Nutella convert
because I'm scared of what my life will
become it's like the first time I went
to Vegas and I won a little bit of money
I was like I need to leave it's perfect
they should call this poo from baby
angels it's just that heavenly